welcome everyone to today's meeting of
the licensing subcommittee
some housekeeping if the fire alarm is
activated please take the stairs down to
the reception area and out of the
building to the Green in Hawley Square
which is the assembly point please do
not use the lifts officers will assist
you and advise when it is deemed safe to
return to the council offices
I would advise that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
areas may have their image captured I
urge anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present I can see there's no one filming
the meeting today
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent and that they are not used to
make or receive calls whilst the meeting
is in progress
um apology for absence I don't think
we've got any apologies
um Declarations of interest uh are there
any Declarations of Interest
no
okay moving on to agenda item three
application for a new premises license
at the smoked Street Kitchen at 92 High
Street broadstairs I call upon Miss
Phillips the council's principal
litigation lawyer to explain to the
parties the procedure that we will be
taking during this hearing
thank you good afternoon everyone I'd
like everyone present to know that the
decisions made by the subcommittee are
made in accordance with the appropriate
legislation which is the licensing act
2003 and the decision is based on the
information that's presented in this
agenda together with any verbal
submissions made today decisions made by
the subcommittee they are not
politically based and the subcommittee
will listen
um intently to the submissions made and
offer a fair and unbiased decision based
on those submissions this isn't a court
process so the procedures quite informal
where here as was said to consider the
application for new premises license at
the smoked Street Kitchen and the
application was made by Jamie child who
is a director of The Establishment
um
I'll just inform you of what the
procedure will be during the process
today we'll hear the parties in the
following order we'll have the licensing
officer first who will give her report
um the applicant
um we will hear next and then we will
hear the respondents
I understand there are no objections by
the police and the environmental health
officer
in relation to as the representations
are made after the licensing officer
makes her report gives her report
questions may be asked to her
by the applicant and by the respondents
and then as the applicant makes his
submissions questions afterwards may be
put to him by the licensing officer and
the respondents
ETC each party has up to 15 it's to make
its presentation but you don't
necessarily have to use up that period
of time you're not required to talk for
that amount of time the heroin usually
takes the form more of a discussion
um led by the authority
and there is really no time limit for
um questions to be asked at the end of
the proceeding Siege party will have
five minutes to make a closing statement
in the same order that you made your
submissions and then at the end
we will ask for everyone to leave the
chamber apart from the legal officer the
Democratic officer and the subcommittee
in order to deliberate and come to a
decision thank you
[Music]
would the technical support team manager
please present the report thank you good
upstairs
um that's attached along with the plan
of the premises
the application was advertised as it
should be under the licensing act and we
received two representations which are
also attached and it says three and four
we didn't receive any representations
from the police the fire service or the
licensing officer and the applicant has
agreed some conditions with
environmental health which you can see
are in the report there and obviously
one of the main conditions there part C
which says that only the internal areas
and the external bar itself are licensed
this means that no music can be in the
rear Garden or in the front garden
because they're not considered licensed
areas
thank you
do members have any questions for the
technical support team manager
okay could I just ask whether the uh the
premises was licensed before yes
um yeah I think it's in the in the uh
the previous license was held it
actually had longer hours than the
applicant Mr childhood asked has asked
for this time and that was surrendered
when the lady gave up the premises if a
license is surrendered someone coming in
can take that license over even if it's
been surrendered but it has to be within
a 28 day period and that it was a longer
period so Mr Charles when he took over
the business had to apply for a totally
new license
um the there's to be no music outside is
that correct so if they did play music
outside
um there's no comeback really it's the
for the local residents
[Music]
yeah yeah they can make they I'm quite
sure Mr Charles won't because he knows
it's one of his license conditions that
he's not allowed to have music outside
but if he does that's obviously against
his licensing conditions and
um residents can make complaints and
obviously because it's not it's against
his licensing conditions he could be
pulled back before the board
yeah but you can't stop it at the time
can you
well I'm quite no you can't and unless
we're informed of it at the time but I'm
quite sure Ben if he's a responsible
applicant then he's not going to
I know I have the experience of this
somewhere completely different
um
so um I mean we were told to report it
to environmental health
if the music is going on somewhere it
shouldn't
um which obviously takes a long time but
okay okay
any further questions from members
we're a restaurant not a pub we don't
we're not interested in having people
coming in just drinking and getting
drunk and causing a nuisance we just
wanted to be able to serve alcohol when
you have a meal
and live music you know maybe once in a
while or during fight week special
occasions and that is it
we're not going to be like a nightclub
yeah could you tell us a bit more about
the actual sort of premises and I know
you've got the outside area we've got a
front deck in and a rear garden and then
the inside obviously and the cocktail
bar has been built purely for space so
that we can make drinks up in and stuff
and then bring them into the restaurant
it's not like we're going to be sitting
at the back playing music all night and
drinking
10 o'clock
it's uh any further questions from
members to Mr Childs
no okay uh does the technical support
team manager have any questions for Mr
Childs
uh Mr Charles do you have any questions
for the support team manager no
okay we have two objection
um uh people making objections Mr shafto
and Mr Williams
um would you like to present your case
to the board regarding your objections
to the premises
okay
um
well good afternoon thank you for
hearing us hearing us um
for the record because I'm not sure how
this went um I'm here on behalf of the
new Parkview right to manage Company
Limited and which represents 14 flat
owners at Parkview I couldn't make this
clear on the online form so I emailed a
Lois here at Sonic District lusts in
technical support team on the 4th of
July to confirm that we've also sent you
the minutes of our June egm which the
residents unanimously passed the motion
to oppose this license
um if I could quickly respond to the
applicant's statement that um within
here
um that I should have known that the
area was not a quite residential area I
quote um his comment about purchasing
their properties due to the quiet and
undisturbed nature of the surroundings
which is surprising when the properties
front the High Street with high footfall
from pubs and other licensed restaurants
including a licensed restaurant on the
corner of Veer Road
well only three of the flats actually
front the High Street the others are on
Via Road and Belmont Place Belmont Road
which are residential streets the cafe
Grill on the corner of Veer Road closes
at 7 30 plays no music and makes no
noise whatsoever
and our flats are nowhere near any other
pubs or any other restaurants I mean
I've lived next door for seven years and
have never heard music played from that
premises once during folk week
when it was Sinatra's I did hear a
poetry reading for at about 10 a.m very
nice it was but never any music
um
so we're objecting on the grounds of
prevention of public nuisance as you
know and as an example of that some of
our residents have been kept awake by
three of the Smoke Street Kitchen staff
members relaxing in the garden after
their shift has ended they get louder
and louder laughing and shouting music
is played from the inside and this has
gone on until 11 o'clock at night
sometimes
uh this has happened on the 7th 9th 10th
11th and up to the 16th of July and by
the way uh the uh songs grease lightning
ironically little respect with two Tunes
blaring out from the inside of 10 30 on
the 14th of July
so what we're saying is Imagine
multiplying that by a factor of eight
raising the volume with copious amounts
of alcohol throwing some swearing and
have live music blaring out from inside
the restaurant can you imagine what the
noise level will be at like at 10 30
every night
I'll ask how would you feel if your next
door neighbor set up a barbecue at one
o'clock in the afternoon at the patio
doors open and with music blaring out
invited 20 or so mates to come around
for a drink and carried this on to 10
o'clock at night seven days a week would
you be prepared to put up with that
um
and as we know you know when the alcohol
goes down the music the noise goes up
as it shows here I have some for the
record
I just put some Google Maps here this is
the green area here in right in the
middle is the um The Garden of the smoke
three kitchen uh and this lot around
here is 19 properties that surround that
and every one of those will be affected
by the noise
um
and of course that doesn't fit with the
authentic council's licensing policy uh
page 12 Section 5 prevention of public
nuisance you say for example five three
of this document states that the
licensing Authority will pay particular
attention whether or not to impose
stricter conditions including controls
on Licensing hours with a view to
protecting the quality of life of
residential occupiers
five seven it says examples of control
measures State the following examples of
control measures are given to assist
applicants and are considered to be
amongst the most essential that
applicants should take account of in
their operating schedule having regard
to their particular type of premises and
or activities 0.4 on that one is very
clear installation of soundproofing
acoustic lobbies and sound limitation
devices are deemed to be the most
essential
none of these are installed in the
garden or the licensed areas
in fact the applicant has let us know
exactly what he intends to do
on the morning of the July the 6th at 11
30 a.m he was seen by a resident of Park
View in the garden take talking to two
colleagues he turned and faced our
building cut his hand around his mouth
and yelled and we are going to be
playing music really loud all week
and this picture here shows the
proximity
of that Garden this is 70 1700
millimeters between that and a bedroom
window at Park View that's the Garden
area there that's our window
so
so imagine music blowing from inside the
restaurant a garden full of noisy
alcohol fuel people seven days a week
would you want to live next door to that
so uh however
we do want to work and have good
relations with our neighbors
so we would like to offer a compromise
here for the benefit of everyone
affected in the High Street Veer Road
and Belmont Road
um
we'd like to suggest that the garden
could be used for eating and drinking
between the hours of 12 noon and 6 pm
after which time it should be close to
customers and staff and that includes
the outside bar when music is played it
should only be inside the restaurant and
that the doors for the garden should
remain closed to minimize the noise
this will solve the issues that concern
as and if agreed should be written into
the con conditions of the license and if
that is the case we'll drop our
opposition
thank you very much
thank you Mr Chef Mr Williams would you
like to add anything no Mr Chateau
speaks for all the residents okay thank
you
uh does uh Mr Childs have any questions
for Mr shafto and Mr Williams yeah we've
asked us shouting about live music
that's absolute rubbish so lots of the
evidence of that that's ridiculous I
didn't shout that at all I know where
that's come from and with the staff
being out in the back Garden or I have a
word with him tell them to keep the
noise down but I have to be in the back
Garden after 10 o'clock because the
store runs there and have to close
everything down
so you know
yeah would you like to ask the
objectives any
um specific questions about what they've
come up with they're the the proposition
no that proposition wouldn't work
you wouldn't you wouldn't entertain that
no because the garden has to be used
until 10 o'clock every night especially
for the staff because they have to go in
and out of the store room
okay
do members have any questions for Mr
shafto or Mr Williams
thank you
I'd just like to um
ask
um no well Mr Charles is the applicant
so not really unfortunately
yeah um I'd just like to um just to
confirm that you you are aware that the
the music is to be played inside and
there's no music to be played outside uh
with this application
[Music]
yeah can I ask whether it makes a a big
difference with with the the premises if
the doors are open or closed with the
music and so what type of music is
played and what sort of volume
yeah yeah
yeah and this is uh the premises is
predominantly a restaurant and uh
yeah so as a restaurant you wouldn't be
playing very loud music in the uh in in
the premises yeah okay
he said there was a lot of swearing and
so swearing going on
okay any other questions for
Mr Childs
um all the uh Mr Chateau or Mr Williams
no
okay uh
thing after we asked the technical
support yeah um does the technical
support team manager have any questions
for Mr shafto or Mr Williams
um just miss Williams
um no sorry I didn't want to miss
Williams I meant I meant yourself Mr
Charles would you be happy to have a
condition that the doors stay closed
when music's being played inside
it depends on the
skin on a hot summer's day we have the
front and the back doorway
to the door as well
I think
uh does Mr shafto or Mr Williams have
any questions for the support team
manager
could you put your microphone on please
um
I'm not sure who this is aimed at but
you're talking about not having anything
open after 10 o'clock agenda three item
Annex one here states that we were
recorded music uh take place indoors or
outside of both and it says both
and it starts at 12 p.m noon and it
finishes at 11 o'clock that's what's on
the
license on
thank you I'm just going to pass this
over to our support team manager for
clarification
Jim but as you can see on the agenda
um Mr Charles has agreed totally
different times and the uh no music with
the Environmental Health Department
so those are conditions going on the
license
thank you
uh yeah other sort of two different
could you uh put your microphone back on
please Mr Jeffco
this is the current situation 0.2 and
it's uh C that condition C above means
that you know no music will be allowed
in the rear Garden or the front decked
area as they are not licensed premises
I've we didn't know that and we're
looking at the application that was on
the paperwork that we've downloaded from
the website which we've put into this
meeting so one of them is we're all
playing of recorded music take place
indoors and Outdoors and will the
performance of live music take place
indoors Outdoors or both live music is
both and that starts at 1pm and finishes
at 10 pm seven days a week
so I'm
an advice
I I understand I'm just looking at what
the license is applying for there's
nothing that's what I'm reading
are there any more questions
um
counselor making sense
I think to the technical support
um
are we able to ask for
noise mitigation measures to be taken
in the courtyard for example soft
um
absorbing surfaces on the walls for
example
you can do
you can put whatever conditions you want
in in your experience does that happen
and does it work
really
I just think we need to clarify that the
music won't be played outside the music
is played in in inside the restaurant
Courtyard it would be open but this is
this is a restaurant it's not a
nightclub I think we need to make that
absolutely clear
yeah
any more questions
okay uh
yeah the applicant term will now have
the opportunity to sum up their case so
Mr Charles would you just like to sum up
your application any last words for them
we are simply a restaurant that would
like to have alcohol with a meal with
regards to the live music it's going to
be on the very rare occasion this is
mainly for folk week and the building
has been licensed for over 20 years
without a single complaint
by Nina that's why she's here with me
today
um and which is simply not going to be
allowed Pub slash nightclub we're a
restaurant selling food and we'd like to
serve alcohol with it and on the old
occasion have someone in maybe a band or
something like that for one evening
and that is it we won't be playing music
out the front we won't play music out
the back won't be encouraging people to
come in and drink
and that is that we're just a restaurant
that would like to serve alcohol with
food like every other restaurant in the
High Street
thank you
um
sure are all the objectives would you
like to um sum up your case yes
um if I can just uh
put some meat on the bones of the of the
music being played which does disturb us
from within
um we have one of the residents made a
list of what was happening so on the 7th
of the 7th 23
at uh 2305 the staff are in the yard
clearing up late to see sitting around
the backyard smoking and chatting and
every now and then breaking into raucous
laughter this is one particular resident
she has Ms and likes to get tries to get
to bed at 10 o'clock so that's sort of
impossible for her
on the 9th of the 7th at 10 45
loads of noise going on in the rear yard
crashing about staff then seen sitting
around the rear talking laughing aloud
noisy noise ceased when the people moved
inside at uh quarter to 11. on the 10th
9 55 loud music was her coming from the
premises at uh
2250 music turned off but attempts to
sleep disturbed by staff and every year
are banging around and dragging
furniture around the year right yard
and so at August 11 it was quite
on the 11th
uh loud reggae music was coming from
inside the premises kitchen door into
rear yard was open at uh quarter to 11
the music ceased then the same person
was deserved disturbed by loud crashing
noise and it goes on so I won't bother
you with that so to sum up is that we've
given you the concerns that you've heard
about the potential related nuisance to
at least 19 properties from this one
Garden
we'd like to reiterate our opposition to
the use of what will be the main noise
which is the evening late night use of
the garden
as we said in our statement no one
should have to live next door to that so
if the applicant is prepared to accept
it which it seems he isn't that's that
would be where we are if we can meet in
the middle somewhere we would be happy
to to help
thank you
I will call the staff meeting today and
I will speak to all my staff about
creating noise in the rear Garden once
we're close when they're tidying up as
simple as that I'll tell them not to and
if they do then
well that'd be repercussions but I will
make sure that doesn't happen that
they're in there cleaning and making
noise with the music on stuff like that
the music will go off at 10 p.m they can
do their cleaning they can have a chat
inside and a laugh if they want inside
and that's that I'll make sure all that
thank you
all the questions and uh thank you very
much with the exception of the
subcommittee members the Democratic
Services officer and the principal
litigation lawyer please can I ask those
presidents to leave the chamber so that
the subcommittee can come to a decision
you'll be invited back for the decision
to be announced thank you everyone
questions
I would like to now invite Phillips the
principal litigation lawyer to read a
summary of the subcommittee's
determination thank you
thank you in this application for new
premises license at the smoked kitchen
the smokes streets kitchen by Jamie
child to thanet District Council as the
relevant licensing Authority Act in
accordance with the licensing act the
decision of the subcommittee having
heard representations from the licensing
Authority the applicant and the objector
is to Grant the application for a new
license subject to the conditions that
have been agreed with Mo environmental
health
thank you
thank you everyone that will conclude
the proceedings for this licensing
subcommittee meeting thank you very much
and that was a long day as well